apple just announced a bunch of new
products in a two-hour keynote who has
that sort of time that's why I'm going
to show you everything in two minutes
let's go first the iPhone 6s if you have
an iPhone 6 look at it and imagine it
with a better processor better camera
and a whole new type of touchscreen
Apple is calling it 3d touch and it
means the new iPhone screen can react to
varying pressure for instance instead of
tapping on an app icon press hard to
peek at what's going on inside the app
or get to shortcuts and the camera app
you can look and see photos you took
right from this screen and see the live
photos iowa's 9 is full of little
shortcuts like these but my worry is
that people won't know what to do and in
some instances it doesn't work right the
iPhone 6s also has a 12 megapixel camera
along with a 5 megapixel front-facing
camera next the iPad pro you know
Microsoft Surface that turns from a
tablet into a laptop well this is
Apple's version the crazy thing tablet
has a 12 point 9 inch screen yes
it's massive though it can double as an
expensive cocktail tray the screen is
great for watching videos and other iPad
stuff but now you can do real work on
the $800 tablet by adding a 130 dollar
keyboard case the keys are a little bit
small but I was typing fast in no time
and to go along with all that Apple did
the unthinkable they announced a stylus
I mean the pencil the Apple pencil you
can sketch with it take notes with it
and draw mustaches on people so with me
next Apple TV the new box has a much
needed interface redesign and a touch
sensitive remote the remote also has a
microphone that gives Siri a big seat on
your couch find she's all that besides
all that Apple is bringing brand new
games and apps to the big screen the
Apple TV will be out in October and will
start at a hundred and fifty dollars
stay tuned to wsj.com for full reviews
of these products as they hit the market
I'm going to see if Siri will make this
a cop